hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
research centers and pharmaceutical
makers are rushing to deliver a
safe and effective covit 19 vaccine but
is the fight to end the pandemic
getting tangled up in partisan politics
health and human services secretary alex
azar responds to concerns
over president trump's refusal to share
coronavirus data
with president-elect joe biden's
transition team and discusses
how the trump administration plans to
distribute 40 million
vaccines by the end of december if folks
across the nation are celebrating or
speaking out against election results
arnon mishkin
director of the fox news decision desk
weighs in on the 2020 outcome
and what he says republicans and
democrats should be focusing on
if they want to pick up those key senate
seats in georgia
plus commentary from jimmy fayla host of
fox across america
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
i'm tom chalu i'm liz peake i'm charles
payne and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday november 18th 2020 i'm jessica
rosenthal
as covet cases surge the president-elect
says his team needs to coordinate with
president trump's team
on the virus or more people will die but
the president's staff insists regardless
of coordination
they're already producing vaccines we
hope we'll have as many as 40 million by
the end of december
that we could begin using across both
both vaccine programs
i'm dave anthony the way the election
ended up
is exactly how never trumpers wanted it
more republicans in the house
him out of the white house if trump had
been able to get
the votes of everyone who voted for a
republican congressperson
he would have carried arizona wisconsin
georgia
and pennsylvania so he would have been
re-elected to a second term no doubt and
i'm jimmy fala i've got the final word
on the fox news rundown
it's a mixed bag right now when it comes
to the virus vaccines are being produced
but governors are implementing new
restrictions as the number of coveted
cases spike around the country
just in time for flu season and some of
the restrictions are different than the
ones we saw in the earlier days of the
pandemic
ohio republican governor mike dewine
announced a 10 pm to 5 a.m curfew
for 21 days to begin thursday look we
know we know the basic
science and we had
the doctors who we normally consult take
a look at this
and the basic science is fewer contacts
fewer spread less spread
so anytime that you can reduce contacts
you know statistically you will reduce
spread other states have already imposed
curfews michigan's governor
re-implemented restrictions but said
kindergarten through eighth grade
in-person
learning should continue dr scott atlas
a radiologist who
is on the trump administration's kova
task force had tweeted that michiganders
should rise up against whitmer's
reimposed restrictions
and told fox news's brian kilmeade's
radio show tuesday
when you can find people indoors that's
going to kill
people when you restrict businesses and
close schools
then you're keeping people indoors where
most of these cases
spread it's sort of counter to contrary
to the data
to do what some of these lockdowns are
are being proposed
but the director of the national
institute of allergy and infectious
disease dr anthony fauci
isn't sure localized restrictions are
enough saying
uniform mask wearing might be in order
and that public health strategies need
to be intensified
president-elect joe biden warned that if
the trump administration doesn't start
coordinating with his folks
more people could die they say they have
this warp speed program that they're not
only dealt with getting vaccines but
also
how to do how to distribute this if we
have to wait until january 20th to start
that planning
it puts us behind over a month month and
a half
and so it's important that it be done
that there be coordination
now but members of the trump
administration say they're on it
regardless of post-election transitions
thanks to president trump's operation
warp speed we have
two vaccines that have now demonstrated
late stage clinical trial efficacy and
efficacy that's frankly off the charts
alex azar is the secretary of health and
human services the pfizer vaccine came
in at over 90 percent effective
modernity came in at 94.5 percent
and in the world of vaccines that is
just um that puts it in the top tier of
public health
vaccines so incredible news with good
safety profiles so
you asked about timing at this point
modern and pfizer will pull their data
together and they'll submit to the fda
applications for emergency use
authorizations and
fda will as quickly as possible but
without cutting any corners review that
data and make a determination whether it
meets the standards for emergency
authorization that they've published
publicly they'll
have a public advisory committee hearing
and we hope we hope this would all go
quickly because
we are producing these vaccines as we
speak we hope we'll have as many as 40
million by the end of december
that we could begin using across both
both vaccine programs but just a
historic accomplishment thanks to
president trump's leadership of
operation warp speed
end of december 40 million wow um
you just mentioned the the words that i
wanted to talk about a vaccine program
uh because i spoke to dr tom frieden the
former head of the cdc earlier this week
he said a vaccine is
only as good as its dissemination
program
talk to me about the strategy is this
going to hospitals and doctors first are
there guidelines to ensure healthcare
workers
and first responders get it before even
maybe say the elderly or vulnerable
what what's what's the strategy so let's
first talk about prioritization of
populations
uh where were you asked about which is
which group should get it uh now i asked
the national academies of sciences to
give us recommendations and they asked
us to prioritize
groups like healthcare workers emergency
first responders and that are more
vulnerable senior citizens
this will go to the cdc and it's called
the advisory committee on immunization
practices an outside group of experts
will give cdc advice but at the end of
the day the director and i will make the
decision on
where vaccines should be prioritized we
need to see the data first
because it may be that a vaccine one
vaccine might be more appropriate
in an elderly population another vaccine
might be more appropriate in a younger
healthier population
we have to be driven by data and science
but suffice it to say
our prioritization will be towards those
most vulnerable
and those for who who would get the
greatest benefit from the use
of the vaccine in the earlier stages but
it'll be it'll have to be driven by data
in terms of actual distribution our
program and philosophy
we have worked with the defense
department leadership using their
logistics and operations skills
to build a program that really relies on
the existing annual vaccination programs
we have through the private sector why
build something new that could break
when we have a well-rehearsed
every year program that distributes over
90 million vaccines for children through
the cdc's program
and 175 million doses of flu vaccine
through our normal flu vaccine program
we want to harness and leverage the
greatness of america's public-private
partnerships here
i was going to say we already have flu
dissemination um so
does that mean we can we can expect a
lot of doctors offices pharmacies
hospitals to be the first recipients
so i think the first recipient
recipients that's gonna get it's gonna
depend on who's getting vaccinated but
uh you're likely going to see hospitals
getting vaccinations
for vaccine programs for first for first
responders and health care workers
you'll see america's great pharmacies
distributing vaccine and inoculating
people so for instance
we have a partnership with walgreens and
cvs
where they can help nursing homes and
assisted living facilities
do the vaccinations for them and we'll
pay for that and over 90 percent of our
skilled nursing facilities nursing homes
have signed up for that program already
again we're just trying to make this as
easy as possible leveraging existing
systems of distribution
but at the end of the day our governors
are going to be in the driver's seat
we're asking them tell us where you want
vaccine to go tell us how you want it
distributed who you want to get it
we're going to give them the cdc
guidance but they'll be in the driver's
seat at the end of the day and we'll
work to accommodate their desires
tell me secretary are you personally
briefing or speaking with anyone
with the incoming biden administration
well we'll wait for gsa to make a
determination
but let me be clear these distribution
programs are being run by career people
at cdc
at the defense department on operation
warp speed
so any transition it would of course be
seamless in that regard
is there any transition happening at all
right now uh we'll wait for gsa to make
a determination on that front my focus
is
on therapeutics vaccines and trying to
get this covered 19 outbreak that we're
experiencing right now as under control
as we can
uh biden said monday that if the
president does not coordinate with his
folks
that more people will die and that they
need to be coordinating specifically on
vaccine dissemination given
given the timeline i'm wondering does
that
does that make sense to you i mean what
do you say to that as
as the leader of health and human
services
listen i spend every day waking up to
try to make sure we're getting vaccines
and therapeutics out trying to reduce
cases reduce hospitalizations
reduce fatalities here that's where my
focus is i'm going to leave the election
issues to other people
but the notion that more people could
die then then is already forecast
to die uh so so that's exactly what we
and our whole team
are focused on is how do we get cases
down how do we get people to practice
uh wash your hands watch your distance
wear your face carvings we can't watch
your distance stay out of settings where
you can't do those things especially as
we move into cold weather indoor
settings
overcrowded indoor restaurants bars and
especially as we move into thanksgiving
and christmas season
family or neighborhood gatherings we're
finding these are some of the
major vectors of disease transmission
as cases increase really almost
uniformly across the country right now
and that's where our priority has to be
because this is a bridge
our behaviors are going to enable us to
bridge to the day when we have these
vaccines out there as we get
even more therapeutics like the lilly
monoclonal antibody that we approved
just last week
that is we've got a bridge to that great
new hopeful future that we have but we
want everyone to make it there and that
takes individual behaviors to get there
and that and the the programs that we
have uh
are are very consistent across all of us
in public health uh
whether the the cur whether the
administration
or uh vice president biden's program and
plan that he's put forward
very consistent just a few more um we're
definitely experiencing a surge in cases
um why what do you
can we trace it back to something is it
halloween i remember we used to say it
was memorial day or july 4th or
labor day what happened here i mean in
california alone
our health officials said that in the
first week of november we experienced
the biggest
increase that we've seen in the entire
pandemic
so this is not event driven this is uh
this is behavior driven as i just
mentioned and we're seeing this is not a
uniquely american phenomenon either i
work with my g7 health minister
colleagues every week
the western european countries in canada
are facing exactly the same phenomenon
in fact western europe was
experiencing 45 percent more
per capita new cases per day than the
united states it's a combination of
factors
mitigation fatigue our people are tired
they've sacrificed so much
and i fear in some instances they
they've given up
on some of the basic protections of
watching distance and wearing mass
wearing mass and distance work the data
shows it at
one meter of distance if you and the
other person are both wearing a face
covering you can reduce viral
transmission by over 70 percent
seven zero percent it protects both from
the spread from one person but also the
receipt from the other person so
wear your mask especially when you can't
practice
social distancing uh people are tired
it's getting cold we're experiencing
with the outbreaks are happening where
it's getting cold and people are losing
the natural social distance that comes
from being out of doors
they're going indoors indoor restaurants
that are overcrowded
indoor bars as well as household
gatherings of neighbors and friends
where they let their guard down we let
our guard down because we think because
we know people
they can't be infected or we can't
infect them that's a fallacy you must
protect yourself and please do it
because
thanks to what president trump is
delivering on vaccines and therapeutics
we have this bright day ahead it is
weeks away i want you to make it there
and that's going to be your behavior
that gets you there
just on that note social media is you
know filled with people saying they
they plan to go to and host thanksgiving
gatherings i i actually got into it with
one woman
who says if california's governor can go
to a birthday party which he admitted
was wrong
then she's just going to go ahead and do
thanksgiving and christmas as usual
my old history teacher said his current
students plan to do the holidays as
normal what do you say to those people
beyond what you just said to me
so the more people you get together the
greater the risk
the less likely you're going to be able
to be social distance the less likely
people will
comply with wearing mass if you can do
it outside if you're going to have a
gathering
outside is better if you're going to be
indoors have as much ventilation as
possible
open the windows as much as you can even
practical things like if you've got a
ceiling fan flip the flip the
the control on it so it's pulling air up
instead of pushing air down
people are going to do what they're
going to do okay but we want to make
sure they're informed of those risks and
minimize as many of them as possible
we're seeing reaction in many places
including more restrictions on
businesses
at the state and local levels and we're
seeing more shifts more talks
more talk of like curfews you know
governor whitmer in michigan
said during their new restrictions that
kindergarten through eighth grade
in-person learning
should continue but but maybe high
schools should not are these kinds of
strategies these different strategies
than we maybe saw in the earlier days of
the pandemic
better or worse in your mind than than
previous
sort of lockdown type strategies well we
now have 10 months of data and
experience not just in the united states
but across our peer
western european and canadian colleagues
to know what works what doesn't work
all of our interventions should be
guided by science data and evidence
uh for instance our schools k through 12
and universities
these are simply not proven to be major
vectors of disease transmission
you know in europe they're keeping their
schools open even as their cases explode
more than the united states
because they put a priority on it they
know the health issues from keeping kids
at home
and they know that in institutional
settings like that they're able to
actually practice appropriate mitigation
tactics to keep the kids safe and stop
from transmission
secretary azar thank you so much for
your time thank you jessica appreciate
the chance to be with you
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
more than two weeks after the election
votes
are still being tabulated they have to
finish a hand recount by today in
georgia many of the counties have
already finished their audit
as we're going through most accounts are
very very close brad raffensberger is
georgia's secretary of state
in floyd county they found a memory
stick
that hadn't been uploaded and so that
added about 800 votes for president
trump
but he still trails joe biden by about
14 000 votes in the only state not
called yet george's 16 electoral votes
would add to biden's 290
which is already more than enough to
make him president-elect though
trump campaign continues legal
challenges in other states
some congressional races have also not
been called republicans have already won
more seats than they have in the current
house burgess owens the latest to unseat
a democrat declared the winner in utah
this week
over congressman ben mcadams owens a
former nfl player told
fox we have to fight toward freedom and
the the concept the culture that our
country was built upon
and we're fighting against the
socialists and marxists republicans may
end up with 213 house seats
i don't think anyone expected to see the
strength that the republican
congressional candidates showed arnin
mishkin is director of the fox news
decision desk
it's interesting when you look down at
the um why the republicans did so well i
think it's a combination of two factors
the first one is it is very clear that
donald trump brought his base out
to vote for republicans and that they
voted top to bottom on for the
republican ticket
and the other thing that contributed to
the republican strength was
that there was a segment of the
republican uh electorate i think
that liked republican policies
but for whatever reason didn't like
donald trump and so you see about five
percent of the folks who voted for joe
biden
voted for uh the republican candidates
for
for house um so they were splitting
their ticket and when you look at that
five percent and we're able to do that
with our fox news voter analysis because
it's
such a large sample of voters when we
look at that
the vast majority of those people i mean
almost 6 out of 10
say they're republicans they're either
liberal republicans or moderate
republicans or conservative republicans
but they're republicans
and i think that you know that's the um
that was the
that made the difference for uh joe
biden why he won but it's it's one of
the reasons why the house
republicans did so well if if
trump had been able to get the votes of
everyone who voted for a republican
congressperson
he would have carried arizona wisconsin
georgia
and pennsylvania so um he would have
been
re-elected to a second term no doubt if
he had been able to sort of get
the support of all those people who
supported republicans
in the congress so are you saying that
in the end that the group of people
who've been out for four years
the so-called never trumpers they
actually
swung the election i i think there's
that there is a theory
there absolutely okay now let's go to
the other side of the coin though there
have been a lot of people talking about
since the election that one of the
reasons that democrats didn't do as well
in house races
is because there was such of a
focus on policies that were too
progressive
to maybe a moderate democrat have you
seen that as well
and those districts that everyone
thought were sort of 50 50 house
districts
they all went republican and those are
districts where
sort of folks are you know solidly
moderate if you will
um they are you know these are suburban
districts these are people who
um are voters who are willing to to look
at both parties they are not solid
democrats
or solid republicans and yeah they voted
republican this time and i believe if
you look at the data
um these are people who thought that the
democrats represented
too left-wing or too progressive a
position or wanted in some way a check
on democratic policies that they feared
a president biden could pursue
every party is a coalition of sorts and
for whatever reason the challenge for
the democrats is that their coalition
consists of people who support things
such as
medicare for all or defund the police or
other things
that other parts of that coalition find
anathema
the battle for control of the senate
comes down to georgia
there are two seats up for grabs in
january
5th runoffs democrats jon ossoff and
rafael warnock are trying to unseat
senators david perdue and kelly lefler
if they do
the senate would be 50-50 with the vice
president harris able to break ties in
democrats favor
if at least one of the republican
senators win
mitch mcconnell remains senate majority
leader and control of congress would be
divided
if i'm a betting person i'm more likely
to bet that the republicans will win
at least one of those seats and
therefore control the senate
um and the reason it's a question mark
this year is is
threefold the first one is that stacey
abrams effort
organizationally um i think is a major
contributor to why joe biden was able to
carry that state
by a little bit um and i know there's
some analysis that says the black share
of the
the electorate actually went down
because the turnout amongst whites was
so high
but um stacey abrams was clearly able
has been able over the past few years
to register enormous numbers of african
americans and that
contributed substantially to joe biden's
win in georgia
the second thing if you look at actually
at the
vote why was it so close donald trump
was able to bring out a lot of vote for
himself
and for republicans down ballot in
georgia the key question in january is
um assuming that the electoral college
will have certified joe biden as the
president-elect at that by that point
will he be able to and how solidly will
he be campaigning
to try to bring out his people in
support of those two republican
candidates for senate
and the third question is that the other
contributing factor to joe biden's uh
victory in georgia
was that he was able to swing a lot of
the sort of
suburban core of uh
atlanta as well as and they swung more
democratic than
than they had done before that was part
of his moderate appeal
there was a lot of talk about suburban
women who were not trump voters that
they didn't
like president trump he's not on the
ballot
january 5th how does that factor in to
democrats trying to win
areas that might have been more
republican in the past
that i think that's the 64 thousand
dollar question of georgia
what happens to those suburban women
they didn't vote for donald trump
but a lot of them voted down ballot for
the republicans and so
without question with donald trump
if you will somewhat out of the picture
because he's um
an outgoing president will those people
still feel the need to go out to the
polls and sort of express
an anti-republican view as they did in
2018
or are they more likely to express a
view that we want to check
on a president-elect joe biden by voting
republican that's the big question
that's what one of the things we'll be
looking for
on january 5th in georgia i assume
there's been a ton of money poured into
this
race we saw that a lot democrats spent a
ton of money on senate races they didn't
win
across the country the bonfire of money
that the democrats spent to try to win
back the senate
and they wound up winning only one and
netting only one seat
in the senate um is truly astonishing
and it does seem that in some of those
states
that money may have backfired for two
reasons one because people are offended
by sort of
out of state money in many states um
this is what i think happened in maine i
think it's what happened in iowa
it's why uh susan collins and joni ernst
who were
thought to be highly vulnerable wound up
winning quite comfortably
the second thing is that that people
don't like government to do too much
most people you know the fringes on both
sides like government to make all sorts
of changes and all sorts of stuff
in either right or left but people in
the middle like government to move
slowly not do too much don't bother me
and um i think that the message the
republicans are going to carry which is
we want to be a check on a president
biden is
could be very effective let's back up
november 3rd
a very long night for you and for a lot
of us watching trying to figure out who
the next president is going to be
it was a very different night i mean you
had president trump leading in states
that
people thought he was maybe going to
lose and that he maybe ultimately did
lose so
it had to be a very hard night for you
it was a challenging night and it was a
fascinating night and
um throughout the evening i thought the
president had a really really good shot
of winning re-election
particularly when we saw states like um
ohio florida and texas go
um i thought you know that for biden to
win he was going to have to pick off one
of those states
um and so i i felt that the president
had a really good chance it only really
shifted
um around five six seven in the morning
when you started seeing joe biden who'd
been
losing in wisconsin michigan and
pennsylvania
which you knew were sort of the the
must-win for joe biden
he'd been losing in those states and as
the votes started to come in
they became a little more blue and then
blue and then
by about seven eight in the morning i
thought if i have to
choose who i want to be right now i
think i'd prefer to be joe biden i think
he has a better chance than
uh donald trump part of what what
happened
that night was the early voting
by mail right that i mean that that is
what shifted a lot of these things
in these states like pennsylvania right
initially we were just tracking people
who voted that day
and then the mail-in vote came through
exactly well exactly i mean i think
it's for whatever reason this time
around because of the pandemic there was
a huge
increase in mail-in and early vote and
moreover because of what the president
was saying
republicans very much wanted to vote on
election day in person
and democrats possibly also because of
what the president was arguing
they wanted to vote early or by mail
and because those votes are counted
differently it was
it was almost as though you had a
football game where
one half of the game only one team is
allowed to play offense and the second
half of the game the election day vote
uh part only the other team is allowed
to play offense
and so in what you were seeing is as the
vote came in as the vote shifted
was more it was often more a function of
how states were counting the vote
than how the voters were voting so the
southern states particularly florida and
texas
we knew that the mail-in vote was the
stuff that gets counted first and we
knew that that was going to tinge blue
and was going to shift red as the night
progressed and that's basically what it
did
um in the northern states where they not
had much experience with mail-in vote
and where they just they count the
mail-in vote after the election day vote
we knew that the night was going to
start off tinging red and that's the
what it did in wisconsin michigan
pennsylvania
and take a number of days before it
started tingeing blue
as the mail-in vote got counted and
that's and that's basically what we saw
but
it was it was very exciting to watch
sort of close up
um but i think it's also it says
something about the way states need to
think about
how they not only how they count the
vote but how they allow people to vote
in the future
arnon mishkin director of the fox news
decision desk good to talk to you again
thanks so much for joining us
thank you david
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fallon
what's on your mind so joe biden
coronavirus advisors are floating the
idea of a four to six week national
lockdown
the crazy part is i've got a ton of
democrat friends who are mad about it
folks don't complain about not being
allowed out of your house if you voted
for a guy who wouldn't leave his
seriously there were more elvis
sightings than biden sightings during
the campaign but as far as the lockdowns
dopey proposals like this are why i
trust hunter biden to pick up my laptop
more than i trust joe biden to pick up
our economy
lockdowns sound compassionate but
trapping people at home leads to higher
rates of alcoholism drug abuse domestic
abuse and suicide and i'm not trying to
downplay the virus but crushing the
economy isn't good for anybody's
economic health either so i say
open it all up the truth is people have
always been willing to take risks to go
shopping this time of year and if you
don't believe me you've never been to a
black friday sale might as well call it
black and blue friday fortunately this
won't be joe biden's call to make until
donald trump leaves office
and the way things are going that might
not happen until easter at which point
we might all have the vaccine be sure to
check out fox across america weekdays
from noon to three with me jimmy fella
at foxnewsradio.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
that's the perino and stir walt i'll
tell you what podcast
dana parino of the five and fox news
political editor chris steierwell
dissect the ins and outs of national
politics
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes